et je maintenant que nous parlions
claude lévi-strauss de votre seul livre
autobiographique qui est célèbre il est
paru il ya bientôt trente ans c'était en
1955 il s'intitule e tristes tropiques
je les relis j'avais lu à 20 ans j'ai
relu à la faveur de cet entretien
et je veux dire je le trouve vraiment
sublime et je trouverai je le préfère j
éprouve encore plus de profits cette
lecture et je déconseille d'ailleurs à
tous ceux qui voudrait aborder votre
oeuvre de commencer par ce livre ne
serait pas se passer le plus chatoyant
parce qu'évidemment c'est le plus facile
à lire
alors est ce que vous vous rappelez que
triste à propos de tristes tropiques
il ya eu un communiqué l'académie
goncourt regrettant que ce ne fut pas un
roman sinon vous aurez donné le bruit je
me rappelle l'année
ça m'a beaucoup surpris est-ce que vous
rappelez un feuilleton de raymond aron
très très élogieux je me rappelle bien
sûr ça comptait beaucoup ça compte
toujours alors j'en profite pour vous
demander au passage les ont été vos
rapports avec aaron g j'admirais
beaucoup l'oeuvre de
aaron et j'avais pour l'homme une très
grande sympathie
en même temps nous nous sommes je dirais
assez peu connu nous nous rencontrions
au hasard de réunions professionnelles
mais je ne crois pas que nous ayons
jamais déjeuné ou dîné ensemble
alors quand on lit ce livre tristes
tropiques on se dit mais pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas choisi la littérature au
sens strict du terme pourquoi n'avoir
pas choisi le roman le théâtre a envoyé
à écouter ça je peux très bien vous
expliquer parce qu'à l'origine tristes
tropiques dans ma pensée c'était un
roman
quand je suis rentré de ma dernière
expédition est du brésil hôte c'était au
début de 1939 et j'avais donc j'ai donc
eu quelques mois pour essayer de me re
est incorporé à la vie française avant
la guerre et la mobilisation et c'est
elle que moi je voulais les utilisent et
j'avais décidé de les utiliser à écrire
un roman est en revanche il s'appelait
tristes tropiques
c'était le titre et puis au bout de 50
pages
je me suis aperçu que j'étais en train
de faire du très très mauvais conrad
pour qui j'éprouve une admiration
éperdue et que j'étais pas fait pour ça
j'ai donc abandonné
et quand bien des années plus tard
1954 jean malaurie m'a demandé d'écrire
un livre pour sa toute jeune collection
terre humaine n'est ce pas qui en était
à ses débuts
euh j'ai écrit celui là qui n'est pas un
roman mais où en souvenir j'ai gardé le
titre de ce qu'il aurait pu être ce
désir tristes tropiques et uniquement
les trois ou quatre pages du roman qui
m'avait paru pouvoir être sauvée ce sont
les pages imprimées en huile à lille
était à peine un coucher de soleil
oui mr juste santé le début du roman est
née seulement se coucher de soleil qui
resté célèbre
c'est vrai ces pages c'est pas je prouve
que vous savez admirablement écrit
raconté dans les détails et j'ai pas
assez d'imagination je ne sais pas
inventer des jeux ne s'est pas créé des
personnages mais comment vous qu est ce
qu un ethnologue sais bien qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui crée lui aussi des
personnages ou bien qu'ils sont vivants
niveau il va dans les détails les
chercher je l'aimais recchi il les crée
la spa si les réinvente
mais enfin c'est parce qu'il voudrait
faire il voudrait être aussi exact et
authentique que possible ils voudraient
copié ses modèles me suis demandé
d'ailleurs en lisant smip si vous n'avez
pas voulu prouver d'une certaine manière
que les ethnologues ont eux aussi une
âme une sensibilité même du style c'est
un livre que j'ai écrit je dirais
presque dans l'exaspération est dans
l'horreur ah ben oui ça n'est pas du
tout ce que j'avais envie de faire
j'avais envie de faire de la science si
vous voulez et tristes tropiques a été
écrit en quatre mois enfin comme le oui
je ne crois plus que ces éditions sont
datés j'ai demandé que les dates soient
réintégrés dans la prochaine édition
livre de poche ça a été écrit exactement
quatre mois et comme une sorte de pain
somme dont il fallait absolument que je
me débarrasse parce que je n'avais pas
le goût de parler moi j'avais pas le
goût de raconter des petites histoires
des petits détails de voyage et en même
temps je suis bien obligé de constater
rétrospectivement qu'il y a dans tristes
tropiques d'une certaine vérité
le scientifique et paix qui est
peut-être plus grande que dans nos
ouvrages objectif
pour autant que ce que j'ai fait c'est
de réintégrer l'observateur dans l'objet
de son observation
c'est un livre écrit avec ses objectifs
s'appelle l'oeil de poisson chat noir
qui montrent non seulement 6 kg hab an
mais ce qu'il ya derrière l'appareil de
photo et donc ça n'est pas une relation
objective de mes expériences et une
logique c'est une relation de moi même
en train de vivre ces expériences
ethnologique et donc avec un tas de
choses que je ne me serais jamais permis
d'écrire dans un ouvrage à ambition
scientifique mais l'exaspération ne se
sent pas du tout absolument pas elle se
sent dans cette espèce de fureur avec
lequel de l'écrit et qui avec la
première édition était vraiment bourré
de toutes les fautes possibles
imaginables même les mots portugais que
j'utilisais puisque ça se passait en
grande partie au brésil
je les avais écrit un écriture
phonétique je me tais même pas occupé du
dictionnaire